so we were just talking there about Iran
the situation and escalating tensions in
the Middle East and do you think that we
are safer now that and Casson soleimani
is dead look I don't shed any tears for
Silla money I fully understand his
pattern of behavior he was essentially
in charge of the Defense Forces for Iran
there their behavior across the region
has been one that has been destabilizing
he has the he has the blood of many
people on his hands his pattern of
behavior has been such that has been
unacceptable and contrary to
international law for a long time
however to take him out at this stage
when there has been escalating tensions
seems to me to not be making the world
safer actually we are taking a major
lurch towards war and we're doing that
because the president is reckless and
hasn't thought through I don't think
what it is that he's doing but it seems
to me quite clear that the Iranians are
going to are going to go into
counter-attack and it means that our
interests our people our forces are of
course under threat you know there will
be more attacks on the tankers we have
relatively lightly armed members of the
armed forces in Iraq for example you
know they are clearly vulnerable we have
civilians there we have embassies in the
region yes of course everyone is now
vulnerable and he didn't even tell us
before he before he he agreed for this
man to be killed in Baghdad I mean
that's the other point is that they
breached Iraqi sovereignty in order to
kill the head of the Defense Forces for
Iran and so how are the Iraqis supposed
to respond to that you know there will
be great pressure on the Iraqis to say
to the Americans in to the British and
the other Western allies that have been
trying to help them fight Isis that they
should leave and so I think that it
makes the whole area much more unstable
and much more dangerous do you think we
could be heading towards a wall yes and
I think the point is this is that what
we should be saying quite clearly now is
we will not be involved in this you know
this is not first of all Donald Trump
should not be doing this there has been
a pattern of behavior from Donald Trump
ever since since the time he was a
candidate he said he was going to rip up
the Iranian nuclear deal now the Iranian
nuclear deal people will remember was
not a perfect agreement but it was a way
of bringing Iran in from the cold it was
beginning to talk to them and it was it
was essentially saying to them we will
stop the sanctions if you stop your
development of the nuclear bomb it was
bringing them in from the cold and it
was also Iran is a very divided country
there is a so-called moderates in
Iranian terms here led by people like
Hani who who are the ones who really
stuck their neck out in order to be able
to be involved with the west and then
there are the hardline theocrats those
that are responsible for holding Nazanin
cigar arackliffe that this general was
part of that mob you know and they are
now in the ascendancy because the more
moderate forces in Iran have been
undermined by the fact that the Iranian
nuclear deal has been torn up I don't
know can the UK government actually do
because as you say we weren't told
I don't know Trump well so we don't have
that clearly at the influence that
perhaps we would like to have over
Donald Trump yeah we clearly don't want
to take the side of the Iranians for the
for the reasons they you have outlined
what can we do so first of all I think
that what we're doing now is too little
in too late you know I not only warned
Dominic Raab
I warned Jeremy Hunt and I want his
predecessor you know that well now the
primary and I said what I like what I
remember saying I remember saying right
to to Boris Johnson I am really worried
that that the president is going to rip
up the Iranian nuclear deal and he said
to me you should spend a bit less time
reading the newspapers I mean it's
ridiculous you know we have been
complacent when did you say that to him
in Pratt in foreign office questions in
foreign office questions I raised with
him my concerns about where the where
the Americans were going and what was
going to happen and one of the reasons I
did was because the chief of staff of :
Powell and : powell people will remember
was the general responsible for the iraq
war his chief of staff said we are going
down the same path as we did before the
iraq war but iraq but a war with iran
will be 10 to 15 times worse in terms of
loss of life and the costs and he said
we have to stop it was wrong for us to
go to war in iraq it'll be even worse if
we go to war with iran and i have been
warning about there
and you know we now find ourselves in
this situation and the question now for
Britain is do we stand firm and say to
the Americans this is the wrong thing to
do we do not drag us into a war we
refuse to be involved in a war and I
believe that when I say that I speak on
behalf of the majority of the British
people who know that the last four you
know wars in the Middle East have we
have gone into with the idea of oh this
is a bad man let's take him out without
any plan as to what the consequences
would be or what it is that we wanted to
be fair to the government they are using
the word as we heard from dominant Rob
their de-escalation again and again I
mean this doesn't sound like someone who
is about to go in a go to war with Iran
but secondly in my point is you're
talking there about the warnings about
the u.s. behavior the way to stop that
is to have influence oh yeah the u.s. no
do you just wonder I mean just to pick
one quote that you said previously about
President Trump you said he's a sexual
predator he's a racist and it's right to
say that I mean do you really think that
this famously thinned skinned man would
heed your warnings if you speaking about
him right well I tell you what I mean my
experience of bullies is that you stand
up to them you know I mean you Teresa
may held his hand and held his hand you
know Boris Johnson does a Donald Trump
kind of impersonation most of the time
you know this is not you know this is
not the way to influence him the way to
influence him is to stand up to him and
say you're wrong and I'll tell you the
other way in which we could influence
him and that is to use our place and the
Security Council you know we rearm the
most important body for the United
Nations and yet what's happening you
know we're not supposed to be just there
to be decorative why aren't we saying
that there should be an emergency
meeting of the Security Council in order
to bring the world together and to say
this must stop the illegal activity both
of America and Iran must stop and the
world has to come together at this point
and the British Parliament and the
British people have to speak with one
voice and say we will not be involved in
this war you know we need to we need to
behave in the same way as Harold Wilson
did when it came to Vietnam and actually
say no to the Americans if people really
care oh then we get involved or not I
mean this is a wall between superpowers
no listen the reason that we care is
because we will be putting our brave
British troops on the line
you know I think about them and I think
about their families I think about the
loss of life I think about the dual
nationals I think about Nazneen cigar
arackliffe and all the other drill
nations who are languishing in jail
wrongly you know and how they will be
vulnerable I think about that the whole
region I think about 83 million Iranian
people you know who are innocent who
will become victims of the war like this
of course we should care you know we
should take responsibility we we are
international players of course we have
other preoccupations and clearly the
Prime Minister has a lot of
preoccupations he's sunning himself
drinking vodka martinis you know
somewhere else are not paying attention
to this it is important that we do it
we've had three Cobra meetings where
mark said well the chief civil servant
has had to chair it because the Prime
Minister hasn't been available are there
any such situation where you could
support ministry intervention of course
when British wouldn't if we are at risk
of imminent attack then of course we
always defend ourselves of course we do
but the less the USA says that they have
intelligent welcomed out attacks they
say so so they say that but well first
of all my problem is is that Boris Jones
the Donald Trump has their kind of a
loose relationship with the truth you
know so I'm not going to take his word
for it on the basis of a tweet that he
says that they were they were they were
a fear of attack we would want to see
frankly if we had a proper relationship
with United States they would contact us
in advance and we would they would say
we are at risk of imminent attack this
is the imminent attack we've always
shared security information with the
United States you know so they should
have told us about it they should have
told us what the imminent attack was or
are we actually talking about you know
them justifying themselves afterwards I
mean Boris Donald Trump is now saying
that he was doing this in order to stop
a war not to start one well how does
that work
he's just sent 3,000 additional troops
into them into the region you know we
have our we have we have two naval
vessels now you know redeployed in the
area it doesn't look like we're walking
away from a war it looks like we're
about to walk into one
okay now I'm keen to talk to you about
as well your
hich for the Labour leadership you've
thrown your hat into the race you want
to take the top job in labor taking over
from Jeremy Corbyn do you think he was a
good leader well can I just first say I
mean up to be honest with you for the
last sort of 24 hours I haven't
necessarily been that preoccupied with
the leadership obviously you know the
fact that we may be proud to go to war
has been my major preoccupation over the
last last day or so and I think that's
only right because I am concerned that
the British government are not doing
enough they are not taking this
seriously
and they are ducking this issue and they
must not we can play and we must play a
pivotal role in this so that's what I've
been doing more than anything else but
looking forward okay so looking forward
I think that actually in a kind of odd
way I mean anybody who becomes leader of
the Labour Party will need to be able to
deal with issues such as this issues
such as the fires in in in in Australia
I mean these sorts of things of what are
going to frame the world it seems to me
so do you think Jeremy Corbyn was a good
leader then I think that Jeremy was had
many many talents and was and I think I
think the reason he was popular in the
labour party was because he spoke from
the heart when he was first elected he
had an authenticity about him that
people found really attractive and he
moved us away from all this
triangulation I think that also he was
he was very important in terms of
winning the argument within the Labour
Party about are simply going down the
road of austerity all the time so I
think that there were lady won they are
great in my country as well as the
labour part well he clearly didn't win
the argument in the country we didn't
win the general election I think that
the Conservatives have moved towards us
and have accepted that austerity has to
end whether they've actually going to do
that or not as of course as another
matter
but you know at least they pay lip
service to to our argument that we have
to stop austerity because the people who
are suffering are those at the bottom of
the pile so no there were achievements
but the most important achievement for
any Labour leader is to win elections we
were established by working people to
look after them in government and if we
can't win elections then we are failing
as a party and the leadership is failing
too and you certainly didn't lose I
didn't win the election it was like
you've got the fewest number of seats
that's read 1930 yeah
why do you think you had such a
catastrophic result I think there were a
number of factors I think that there was
I think there are all kinds of
criticisms in terms of the way in which
the election was organized I think that
that was it was done very badly I think
that we weren't sufficiently clear about
what our parish is where I think that
there's nobody if anybody looks at the
manifesto they can't say well don't like
this or don't like that but there was
too much in it we didn't have he
wouldn't trust her well it just it just
wasn't convincing because there was too
much in it and in the end you know we
can say until we're blue in the face
that there is another way and there is
but we won't get the opportunity to
serve if people don't believe us and
they don't believe in us and if we're
not competent and if we're not
trustworthy then they won't give us the
chance to do it so where we need what we
need to do in my view is not have some
sort of existential crisis about who it
is that we are we know who we are the
part that the country in a way knows who
we are but we need to be clear about
what our plan is where we're going and
in order to we have to be able to
convince people that we have certain
priorities and those priorities of
theirs we need to make sure that we
listen to the country and we look and we
listen to what their problems are and we
put forward solutions in a way which is
meaningful and they they can believe in
us one of the other big issues of course
from the election was brexit
I just want to have a look at something
that Caroline Flint said on this show
before Christmas something you come back
against very strongly Caroline Flint
formal Abram who lost her seat in don
valley said this i don't believe anybody
who has been the architects of our
european policy in the last few years is
credible to be leader and then she went
on to say kirsten led us down the path
of a second referendum and i'm afraid
emily Thornbury did as well she said to
one of my colleagues I'm glad my
constituents aren't as stupid as yours
now you've come back saying that's not
true you're pursuing legal action well I
can't I mean you can see in the hands of
my lawyers I mean I've issued a letter
for action and you know I would need
that along with everything else I need
to do next week I need to see my
solicitors and we need signature it so I
mean there's a you know you can't just
maybe not rubbish about me and not
expect me to take legal action I mean
I'm always I mean people can slag me off
and they do but so long as they do it on
the basis of truth
take it on the chin but if you start
making things up I have to take legal
action and I have done
I'm afraid on three or four previous
occasions and when newspapers have said
things about me that aren't true and
when my political opponents have said
things about me that aren't true and it
looks like I may have to do it again how
about the even though she's a Labour MP
which is no I I deeply regret that we're
going to need to do this but if we have
to do it we have to do how about the
wider point that people like yourselves
and KO samet should not lead the Labour
Party because she backed a second
referendum well I think that I think
that we shouldn't have had a general
election on a single issue I think that
what we did that we gave Boris Johnson
power by allowing him to wrap himself up
in the lie that he could get brexit done
by the end of January because it won't
be done we will need to continue to
negotiate a relationship with Europe and
what obviously we will be leaving at the
end of January and we but you know
getting brexit done will also mean
negotiating an ongoing relationship
because 50% of our traders with Europe
and frankly there's another 40 trade
agreements with the rest of the world
that simply come from us being part of
the European Union and we're going to
have to negotiate all of those as well
and he says that he can do it by the end
of the year obviously this is an ongoing
issue that we're going to need to deal
with my point is this to close week
because we agreed to a general election
and because it was going to be a brexit
election I think that was a mistake I
think that if we wanted to deal with a
single single issue we should have said
we should have said let's deal with that
single issue by having a referendum a
general election is not a referendum and
we thought that we could change the
subject you still want to remain now
after the election oh I think that it's
in Britain's interest to remain in the
European Union but we're leaving so what
do you do I mean I'm a practical
pragmatic politician we're leaving at
the end of January so what's important
now is that we ensure that we have a
relationship with Europe that's going to
work for jobs in the economy and just
want to quickly show you a Yuka poll
that was done this week on labour
members and who they want to see it the
next Labour leader you can see here this
is the percentage of first preferences
so Kirsten Malaya and the head yeah 31
percent Rebecca nan Bailey 20 percent 6
percent have you got chance
well I remember looking
back at the other two leadership
elections and Andy burnin was absolutely
gonna win the last one and David
Miliband was absolutely gonna win the
one before I mean it hasn't even started
yet so we've got a busy week in front of
us we will see what the rules are worthy
the campaign's will be launched we'll
have some hustings we're going to go
around the country and and let's see
what people actually think because you
know as I say the campaign hasn't even
started yet
just finally just looking at some of
these faces here it's more women than
men and actually more women potentially
ending entering the contest as well
you've previously said that it's
embarrassing that the Labor Party's
never had a female leader would it be
embarrassing if in a contest where war
more female candidates are standing the
mail that they runs up with another male
leader look let's make sure that we get
the best candidate I mean obviously
that's got to be that's got to be the
most important thing and it'll be for
the members to decide but I think that
the best candidate happens to be a woman
but let's see what they say okay thank
you very much for coming over
welcome to speak thank you